I believe titanfall has a bunch of new
DLC expeditions finally come out three
new maps and some other nonsense uh in
the dlc proper is the three new maps but
it came along with a patch that has
updated a bunch of stuff in turn their
tweaks with gameplay and also with a
sort of the menu system and how you get
into that stuff depending on what
platform you're on as well as bonito
knows well yes Benito Gonzalez you've
been playing this on PC and I believe
you're not very happy not happy with
some of the updates that this patch is
not happy at all like okay so this came
out with a 20th but what is it 50 15 it
came out last Thursday and like it came
out that day and they released the patch
notes the day before it and they were
stuff there was stuff first of all the
patch notes that by working the patch
nuts okay in the game I weren't
passionate a major thing for example
being that in capture the flag you feel
like grab flag hop in your Titan dash
dash dash yeah known as Titan camping
yeah yeah you can't bring the flag into
your Titan anymore nor if a flag is on
the ground can you walk over it with
your Titan to return it like the titans
and flags are now oil and water and this
kind of something that the community
wanted like everyone thought it was
super cheap that you can get in there
tight and just have well like I was it
like unreal tournament or any of those
games when every did CTFU couldn't go
near yeah well they don't bring these
vehicles well no 83 there were in the
other ones you could use that weird
skateboard they gave you more but you
weren't Elegua near yeah yeah so like
people are happy we're like everyone was
stoked right but and then the day after
that on PC at least this isn't true for
Xbox one bond pc they removed CTF and
pilot hunter as modes they're just gone
they remove them from the matchmaking
matchmaking much so you can still get at
those modes but you have to play variety
pack variety pack or private lobby you
can't refuse to go I want to play CTF
game on the play CTF game matchmaking
wise and if you look at my if you look
at my overview like I have like 85% CTF
because I that's kind of all I played a
mole CTF after the first like we just
like leveling up in stuff i was just
playing Jeff and I was super psyched
about the patch right but you mess I was
like [ __ ] yeah I knew Matt yeah but the
new maps so the new maps have their own
lobbies like and we're actually getting
into a match right now in war games this
is cool map to the za but I
the maps are the blobbies on variety
pack there's an attrition there's a
there's an attrition of Jin Han sorry
Steve Bobby on xbox one as well but yeah
you got it that's how you get into it
and so it begs the question why did they
remove it yeah it's got to be a player
pop well they they said something you
know on their forums I think last week
and they said it was something about
sort of a population of that yeah pilot
hunter and CTF weren't popular modes so
I guess to take that population out of
there and put them into [ __ ] variety
pack or electrician or whatever it seems
like they're like to me like I stopped
yeah I stopped same time to fall because
I couldn't that sounds like they're
running some users experiences to make
their matchmaking stuff work better but
I feel like that problem is on them and
not on people about the game yeah
totally like they're gonna piss together
we're used to there better ways yeah
like especially on a pc when you used to
like at least star verb browsers or
thurs like a yeah no sermon browser on
pc and i think that was the biggest
shock for Benito he's telling me about
this man this is just like yeah that's
how it goes on consoles you don't you
know you're beholden to what matchmaking
playlist you you have but that's not the
case on PC any more depth on typology
alright so this is war games this is one
of the three new maps just mopping up
some grunts and as you saw there they
didn't actually die in bloody spatters
they'd like disappear like they d red
basically oh so this is a this is
actually not this is a training ground
type map watch it you can see this looks
like the tutorial basically pilots
disappear to between parts yeah the
pilots disappear as well so all this but
it's also sort of blended with you know
the this realistic stuff so it all takes
place in your mind and maca sitting on
my ear that is a Tron simulator it's a
Tron simulator yeah there's no bicycle
light cycles unfortunately that there's
no other vehicles besides lit d-don't I
like to Darlene if it is a little more
of some parts of this map like lots of
punches map are in like other maps
really like sections of this map our
plights of other man okay yeah so like
this part looks to me like one of the
like the hallways from rise no I for
example but I'm not sure if that's
actually true because a lot of this sort
of like industrial rusty frontier that
sign things on call and this sign
yeah right in Angel City city so it's
sort of a mishmash and it allows eat it
did they use all the stuff they made
already and make a map out of all the
stuffing well let's do it the story is
that this was a deaf man okay the map
you're developing maps on right they
didn't put it in the final game well
that's the story we'll see i don't know
this because I'm already thinking just
so many three maps in this DLC and now
this one Steve's to be fifty percent
made us watch this one's already played
is like a great clip show map yep sure
will quickly show the map we get Vince
back on the show please it got some
questions to ask and if you have any
questions actually yourself you're
watching the show by all means send them
in via the usual method sentiment which
shot game squawk comments or odd game
spot on the twitters my kick like it's
not long enough anybody you don't I were
talking earlier I feel like you should
have a dhalsim booth burn card it like
gives you an extra long load on your leg
yeah that'll be great that'll be
hilarious ah no new bern cards just new
maps the other other some other tweaks
in the the most recent patch which you
get I mean you get that for free that
stuff is not behind the 999 you got to
pay for this map pack I'm season passes
waiting 40 25 25 ok I have any yeah see
Fox gonna be it's 24 99 for free plan
DLC okay have they alluded to having
something a bit more substantial like
having Titans or burn cards or anything
to digital straight up maps and I
haven't heard but I hope so you know
what I'm not really sure they have
probably not mark items maybe guns I'm
guessing problem with that is you know
you you're just sort of creating further
segmentation in terms of your player
population and like you can't can't have
certain college jump that's pretty good
not them to do alright see you pilot but
it might not be it might just be a past
like like they stuff yeah I think why it
should be in these just for everyone
yeah yeah you want you wonder in those
situations who's like we asked depends
on the show if they were beholden to EA
to ensure that they had some sort of DLC
pack and said that they weren't that
this out and they wanted to do which you
know it's a multiplayer shooter it makes
sense to wanna you know yeah freshen up
give your give people some know it makes
sense that the community make maps
that's the thing I'm the win this one
here in front of the news k it again
last week it was like especially in as a
PC version of the game it's all right
all the best match eventually come from
the community I'd like not to be super
reductive about how games are made but
this is using the source engine so like
I'm not saying no move I'd like to see
Dustin titanfall yes can you imagine
okay great to force hmm ok this oxy
seems like a really bad do for me i
robot is so mad and I play Portal 2 as a
Titan please move I think Aztec might be
for Aztec review as yeah what's your
favorite in the twitch what's your name
a counter-strike map he won't realize
the time for- compact escapes your my so
whenever was it to lay on this or
something acidic didn't get bumped back
a week and they never announced a week
okay we're there to come out so it just
kind of came out it's not out for xbox
360 i right
okay in keeping with did you just could
you just a satchel you something
technically I did not satchel myself
this guy killed me before I could
satchel myself the shaving saving me
that ultimate indignity all that much
not that much of a save l was pretty bad
that's how they said with your next DLC
is like to come in no they didn't
announce the date for this one until the
week it came out dude else I believe in
the house what was in it yeah so there's
two other maps this match is not going
well for my team I turned to the battle
I'm socks with yourself it's not not
because of that that dude please kill
that dude how much how much do you think
so nicely how much legacy think
titanfall highs in relation to like its
core popularity because we've got III
coming up we're gonna hear about the new
call of duty there's gonna be watchdogs
coming there Wolfie times okay that
doesn't multiplayer but like we're out
at the sort of the the q1 of death
periods do you think titanfall have you
seen like a drop in the amount of people
playing at all on pc i shall have yeah
it was like they're definitely has been
on pc especially to do you know to
necessitate the kind of thing that the
needles talk was complaining about the
the matchmaking right change that's
going to just mess you up i would say
that yeah the player population is
probably gonna is you know as you know
hopefully seen a resurgence because of
this but it's no you know this is not
like a lot going on in terms of other
you know modes and stuff to get to yeah
I / stuff you're cute i'm on xbox one is
a claim it's yeah it's very good I want
server population numbers for PC that's
what I want to see I want to see like
what what are the numbers if it booted
through Steam you'd be able to see that
probably is though well and is there a
way it's like picking your map you know
that on a much make knows not is there
not only private private lobby actually
the only way to really do that
right oh yeah but no one pays campaign
mode anymore do you see a but do you
think folks are doing private lobby
stuff because would it be interesting it
they definitely are like I'm actually a
part of the reddit community the total
pc master a shout out to ma she and they
do like friday private by the lobby of
your games stuff like that it exists but
it's not super it's not huge yet yeah
not in TZ community you just wonder with
the more maps they release then the more
picky people are gonna come which might
push more people towards private servers
and then exacerbate the problem they're
having yeah with folks looks like
there's no way like right now it's
private servers though you have to know
it from some outside spot right we can't
there's no way from within titanfall to
find private get okay oh so you just
friend you have jumping into french
games or like yams or you need to know
we're getting to a match with all right
so this match is concluding what will I
think we'll do is try to escape and then
start another match we can get a glimpse
of one of the other maps cool yeah yeah
it's just a good to have a look at one
of them good is there Arthur and much
making for just the new pack is there a
DLC only option okay do they have that
fur dummy looking down xbox one wanna
[ __ ] that run right into cluster missile
is it just the Tris there is expedition
variety pack and expedition attrition on
xbox one matchmaking in addition to the
five core modes or in addition to
attrition hardpoint CTF five hunter a
variety pack which won't I don't think
they will ring in attrition maps that's
a great strategy do the old cluster
missile right by the entrance to the hip
bones yeah yeah so some of the other
tweaks they did with the patch we talked
about this during the live stream last
week but like you know stuff like an
auto Titan is not going to enter a the
protective dome of another of an enemy
Titan and kill itself you know what else
is also like little tweaks nuclear
ejection is a little bit more deadly to
tighten the Kramer has like I think it's
more powerful and they made it I'm gonna
be more powerful you know someone in one
hit the mid the amp Craver do more
damage to Titans oh oh interesting no in
title games will sort of post-release
weeks you get weeks in and out of X
mm-hmm and yeah what would you like
seeing a burn card I'm sorry burn pile
yeah like you burn chasm between dhalsim
nice for you well so what at whataburger
like you know you've got the amped
weapons so there's no there's no new one
of those without a new bern card this
sort of ones that affects all those are
this tide pretty much the perks these
are tied to your tactical abilities I've
never gotten that one before I'd run it
so it's permanently stims okay always
stim there's a longer cloak there's
longer a curator called something else
before maybe there's like I mean there's
smuggled their prosthetic Lagos the
different seen that in general this
replaces your ability with a longer stem
this is always stemmed what the
difference between that one in the
faster one the other one that this is
just your mood you move faster the
adrenaline is faster than prosthetic
legs I don't know man I'm the male
scientist unclear but on it reality
check I would guess that prosthetic legs
faster movement speed is not quite as
fast as stim speed but stim isn't just
speed it's also health regeneration
that's right and that exactly effect
when you're running I just do that with
my isn't that what isn't that just when
your damage isn't it it's like titanfall
sand effects all right so I feel like
you see you see the most of it's like
it's it looks really cool it plays well
you can make all sorts of Star Wars
references where the wookies exactly you
see your logo for the kiddie walks no
he's going for the cacique reference
which I respect cuz it's you know
planning with a lot of tall trees I
don't think he wouldn't I don't know if
he knowingly haven't a clue I don't
think he knows garden mode turn up yup
use the fall ready yeah it's dark Paul
Bernard you're a wizard Harry can pick
it up pop-culture illiterate Danny
O'Dwyer gotta love them so this has like
engage its got like a sort of modern
industrial facility in one corner this
old temple area in another which you
might recognize from like lagoon is that
kind of its that style nestled in your
woods the woods which basically yes so
there are these trees and you can like
zip line up into the canopy or you can
ride on these um you can run along sort
of broke down
trees that serve as ramps I feel like
these are these things yeah so this is
one of the remember of those pictures
that leaked before titanfall k maro
people are talking about the creatures
for a while I just saw yeah pretty sure
this is the area that that was a showing
off this one like run up a big mossy
tree really high appetite is to get
really hot mushrooms is up are you able
to effectively run and hide over here on
this tree like wall jump from tree to
tree it depends on the tree that you're
in o lover that guy go can be done
there's one more rare it's not super
cool on last night's Fanning actually
it's great in Titans and I'll show you
why when i get a Titan in a little bit
just because it's the trees are pretty
thick at their bases but they're also
slippery and wet I like it mmhmm yeah
that's exactly what I was gonna say that
nailed it all right we're gonna get it
get a couple more kills here we're gonna
cook callers day I want to see you smoke
oh well that's that Chris waters I go
for Marsha showing up I mean do is it
blood something no one all right get to
zipline getting I don't know where the
finest yeah there's one over there here
i'll try to tree run over there to it
yeah that was next week on the law
business beginning when we play all of
when I'm favor playing titanfall counter
strike hits in time before I go up on a
tree trees office here we go here's
officer be good with Titans like that
blows fun outside way you cannot like 12
times of you guys on the [ __ ] whoo great
nope I was not saying no to you you can
throw you can toss to whatever you want
Ori that I was yelling at trees that is
Titan full from respawn entertainment
coming soon to an xbox one that's
expedition 2 DLC your energy is
incredible happening one you are really
really nailing it get that season pass
if you want to play three new maps one
of which you've already played a bunch
of all right we're going to